[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue au bonheur des
livres nous allons parler avec Mathieu
Falcon bonjour Mathieu bienvenue sur
l'antne de public c'est là le roi et nu
c'est publié aux éditions Alb Michel
mais évidemment il y a ce petit joue sur
la jaquette du livre qui prouve
qu'évidemment ce livre qui est un roman
est ultra polémique et c'est pour ça que
nous vous avons invité car c'est à la
fois passionnant et en même temps
évidemment légèrement déjanté vous êtes
d'accord avec moi que c'est un des
projets que vous avez et en plus ce cher
Mathieu vient d'exon-provence une ville
que nous aimons particulièrement euh
France Olivier gisberg il est inutile de
vous le présenter c'est le plus brillant
de notre génération c'est pas de la
flagornerie il a dirigé à la fois le
nouvels Le Figaro le point publi le très
nombreux livres donc voici le dernier
c'est le 3è tome de son histoire donc
intime de la 5e République tragédie
française le voici le voilà nous allons
parler de tous ces présidents nous
allons parler de cette envie inventée
par Mathieu euh du président Macron
d'accéder à une certaine forme de
monarchie constitutionnelle par le biais
d'un référendum c'est assez amusant mais
Fran il y a quelque chose évidemment je
ne peux pas m'empêcher d'évoquer avec
vous c'est cette manière que vous avez
de parler de vous très personnellement
dans cette histoire politique et
notamment quand vous racontez cette
histoire avec naed qui était donc la
compagne d'un célèbre marchand d'armes
mondial qui était l'épouse et avec
laquel j'ai vécu pendant 5 ans voilà
mais vous dites mais quand vous faites
la description de la place des
États-Unis du petit appartement où vous
viviez avec à la fois des v Gog des
monnais et CER et en même temps diriger
le Figaro on se dit ce type est un
dingue ah ça c'est possible ça c'est
possible oui oui je pense que j'ai il y
a beaucoup de dingerie en moi euh vous
dites je me prenais pour prou oui
effectivement d'ailleurs j'ai commencé à
écrire à ce moment-là un livre sur un
grand roman alors vraiment il faudrait
que je retravaille parce qu'il y avait
trop de personnages CIT pas vraiment
publiable espèce de gros machin qui
était sur sur le monde l'univers
l'univers des riches parce que vous
alliez au Figaro dans la journée le soir
elle faisait des dîners gigantesques
sauf parfois dites-vous quand recevait
Shimon Perez qui vous parlait des futurs
accords d'Oslo qui étaient négociés par
ITAC Rabin donc ça c'était des dîners
plutôt intimes mais autrement c'était
versaill quoi vous étiez invités tous
les soirs à Versailles c'était plus
compliqué que ça parce que voilà on
pouvait prendre le métro attendeaz c'est
moi je non je faut voir aussi comment je
suis comment je vis et et je pense
queabord j'étais très heureux avec elle
c'est quelqu'un que j'ai aimé mais
euh si je raconte ça c'est parce que ça
ça fait partie de ma vie et j'ai rien
voulu cacher c'est tout c'est aussi bête
que ça et c'est pas un livre où je règle
des comptes avec qui que ce soit
d'ailleurs parce que c'est pas mon sujet
le sujet c'est de mettre tout ça en
perspective avec cette histoire intime
parce que histoire in team ça veut dire
quelque chose c'estàdire je je j'hésite
pas à dire par exemple que en 1989 euh
année de la chute du Mur l'événement le
plus important pour moi et encore
aujourd'hui quand je pense à 1989 c'est
la mor de ma mère c'est c'est c'est
important ça aussi pour je pense
que P pour bien vous avoir lu et pour
vous connaître ça éclaire aussi le rôle
un peu 19èiste j'allais dire des
journalistes des illusions perdues et en
même temps une grande lucidité de votre
part par exemple j'ai beaucoup aimé le
passage sur baladure où au fond vous
dites Édouard baladure bon il y a eu les
privatisation il y a eu une retraite une
réforme des retraite qui concerne le
privé mais il y a d'abord et avant tout
eu la la mort de deux personnages qui
ont touché les Français à savoir Léo
feré et Jean Carmet donc évidemment à ce
moment-là on a envie de rire mais on va
revenir non mais c'est la vérité aussi
vous savez que c'était important Jean
CARM leat d'Emmanuel Macron qui démarre
avec la mort d'alidé bah oui mais c'est
il était plus question de Macron il
était question d' Matthieu Falcon le roi
est nu donc je le disais c'est un roman
un roman plutôt déjanté c'est ce qu'on
appelle une dystopie maintenant donc
vous imaginez Mathieu je suppose que
vous avez un peu ça dans la tête que à
aucun moment le président de la
République n'a le moindre envie de
quitter le pouvoir et qu'au dernier
moment il va nous inventer une sorte de
référentom dont vous dites d'ailleurs
qu'il le remportera pour accéder ou pour
transformer la 5e République qu'on
qualifie souvent d'ailleurs de monarchie
en une véritable monarchie dont il sera
le premier roi de la nouvelle version
c'est Michel 1er c'est ça l'idée oui
c'est ça l'idée euh après évidemment
c'est un roman donc c'est du radical oui
c'est radical et on est dans une
transposition donc on n'est pas vraiment
dans des person personnage existant
c'est c'est comme vous dites une
uneucronie enfin on est dans le dans la
fiction mais il est vrai que cette 5e
République donc qui est très monarchiste
enfin en tout cas c'est un peu comme ça
que de Gaulle l'a l'a voulu il me
semble aujourd'hui on est à un moment de
crise et on
a en même temps un président qui a
peut-être des ambitions qui en tout cas
pourrai se les permettre mais est-ce que
le romancier que vous êtes a la Conv i
profonde qui n'a aucune envie de partir
et qui va tenter quelque chose
franchement ou est-ce que c'est vraiment
une réflexion de fiction non c'est de la
fiction moi je je n'en sais rien je ne
connais pas Emmanuel Macron donc je je
sais pas du tout ce qu'il a dans la tête
mais puisqu'on a un président jeune et
brillant en fait l'idée c'était de se
dire qu'est-ce qu'il pourrait faire
après est-ce qu'il n'essit pas ça est-ce
que en même temps on a ce comment dire
cette envie de retour de la monarchie
qui est toujours un peu sous-jacent en
France qui a évoqué luimême d'ailleurs
au départ dans la campagne de 2017
exactement en disant qu'il nous manquait
un roi donc c'est un peu joué sur sur
cette ambiguïté là alors ça commence par
une scène avec un conseiller du
président qui est en train de corrompre
un écrivain qui est un peu
borderline de droite pas très content il
mange du riz de veau tranquillement et
au fond il lui fait miroiter la
possibilité de faire un hi dans
entretien avec le Président de la
République contre la possibilité
d'espionner des milieux de droite ou
d'extrême droite et de lui rapporter un
certain nombre de renseignements ça
c'est la première scène après il y a une
deuxième scène où le président de la
République que vous mettez en scène auss
6i il va voir une de ses conseillères
qui s'appelle si M est bonne Soline
c'est ça et lui demande bah en gros de
noyutter c'est ça qui devient
intéressant ce que Macron c'est ça que
vous lui mettez dans la tête a dans la
tête à savoir que c'est pas du du
toutous les partis politiques qui se
couchent à chaque fois après justement
ce référendum gagn mais les youtubeurs
les adistes les apprentis gilets jaunes
et cetera et cetera et c'est comme ça
que vous inventez une multitude de
personnages qui représentent cette
galaxie là ou et ça commence justement
par ce déjeuner donc par un truc qui est
fondamentalement antidémocratique c'est
la manipulation et l'envoi du raide
partout il y a des types dangereux oui
c'est ça parce que dans le roman en fait
on est un a une période de basculement
et c'est un pouvoir qui donc qui fait
une espèce de coup d'état euh ce
président Michel donc il est évidemment
un peu sur la défensive il se dit
qu'est-ce qui va se passer autour et on
a toute une frangeche de personnages qui
sont un peu effectivement en marge de la
société et qui aimait bien repr CIT il y
a un youtubeur ouais euh il y a donc un
jeune étudiant qui vient de milieu
ouvrier très pauvre mais qui en même
temps a fait des études très brillantes
à normal sub qui rencontre une jeune
femme femme qui est une technophobe
absolue et qui déteste tout ça tout ça
alors c'est donc évidemment le youtubeur
il ressemble un peu papacito et c'est
vraiment plutôt la droite de la droite
les 44 la version des rappeurs de droite
quoi oui voilà un peu viriliste ce ce ce
retour là voilà mais on lui envoie alors
il se fait embarquer par un commando qui
essaie de le sauver du pouvoir c'est
aussi une des scènes qui est assez
réussi dans lieu et à partir du moment
où ils l'ont embarqué 10 minutes après
débarque le raid sur ordre du conseiller
et de la conseillère qui qui ont
l'intention de péter ses disques durs
d'enlever toutes les les les les vidéos
qu'il a faites pour critiquer cette
forme d'accession au pouvoir donc c'est
un peu un poard au début oui oui il y a
cette il y a cette formme là ouais et
mais après c'est vraiment moi ce que je
trouveais intéressant c'est en fait
comment reprendre un peu le pouvoir sur
sur sa vie c'est-à-dire qu'il y a on lit
dans de bord dans la la société du
spectacle il explique qu'en fait on on
est dans un entré dans une phase
capitaliste où en réalité on est plus
que dans la contemplation du monde on
est devenu passif et le monde avance
sans nous et ces personnages là en fait
essaient de reprendre le pouvoir sur sur
leur vie sur sur la marche des choses
donc essayer de contrer d'une certaine
manière un système qui avance tout seul
en roue libre et évidemment ça va être
un petit peu compliqué mais il y a cette
voilà il y a cette notion de de
personnages qui forcément sont
h et qui ont envie de contrer un système
qui a l'air de fonctionner tout seul le
dernier point que je voulais évoquer
avec vous parce que c'est un roman Toufu
c'est qu'un peu comme et ça c'est quand
même un hasard un peu comme humus de
Gaspar Kenig ça se termine ça me
rappelle dant qui y a 10 ans dans
Babylon Babies ça se termine dans une
espèce d'apocalypse du côté de la place
de la Concorde avec le raid contre les
manifestants sa canarde dans tout tous
les sens tout le monde essaie de
s'échapper et c'est quand même une
vision totalement apocalyptique oui oui
mais alors j'assume ça j'étais assez
influencé par Dantec
effectivement voilà et et j'aime
beaucoup il a des des romans
complètement foutraac où
effectivement les mecs qui font venir
des bibliothèques de livres de
scholastiqu aux États-Unis pour sauver
le monde enfin il il y a ce truccl que
j'aime beaucoup chez lui et ce côté
aussi les ça bouge toujours en fait les
mecs qui partent avec une voiture et qui
vont ers un continent entier et moi
j'avais ce ce désir dans le roman aussi
de pouvoir traverser la France et que
les personnages en fait ils ont à hoch
quelque foois ils sont allés sur il sont
AR habite à ongle un tout petit village
et et et ça permet de de parler des
paysages de la France aussi et donc de
cette France qu'on parfois on oublie un
peu dans le dans la littérature
contemporaine je trouve et et de cette
on va dire cette France profonde en fait
ce pays réel quoi et donc cette ce ce
Macron que vous inventez parce que c'est
la fiction c'est un roman
ce que je trouve intéressant c'est que
vous ne faites pas non pas que le
détester mais vous considérez qu'à la
limite aujourd'hui les Français sont
très ambigus par rapport à lui et c'est
pour ça que vous donnez un intérêt à la
littérature c'est qu'au fond il le
déteste dans les sondages il n'aime rien
de ce qu'il fait mais il serait foutu de
le rélir demain matin s'il fallait
peut-être dans 6 mois et donc peut-être
de de lui donner justement une sorte de
pouvoir monarchique
euh oui je pense que beaucoup de choses
sont possibles effectivement et après
bon c'est pas dans le dans le roman
évidemment c'est pas Macron c'est un
c'est un personnage qui en est inspiré
mais qui s'appelle Michel et on est dans
une Mathieu oui alors ça c'est Mathieu
on revient sur Terre on me prend pas
pour un
débile je ne suis pas totalement
responsable de ce de cette couverture
non allez j'ai terminé non non non mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que évidemment
le personnage
est inspiré d'Emmanuel Macron et ça
n'aurait pas été possible sans lui ce
roman en fait après je ne sais pas du
tout ce que Emmanuel Macron fera en
2027 je pense que personne ici ne le
sait mais je trouvais intéressant ce
d'imaginer cette possibilité d'un retour
à une à une forme de de monarchie de
verticalité de quelque chose qui
surplomberait en fait quand on arrive
dans un moment de crise et qu'on a un
pays qui
se est pas loin de se voilà de se
dissoudre et de entretuer en fait mettre
que quelqu'un arrive l'homme
providentiel en fait on a toujours ceou
c'est ce qui avité de 2017 après une
visite à Philippe de Villier il avait
évoqué justement cette espèce de
nostalgie française du du fait que Louis
X soit passé la guillotine alors le
roman est très réussi le roman vous
allez évidemment rester avec nous parce
qu'on va bavarder tout ça avec France
tout à l'heure il tient à la fois du Pol
de la dystopie on parlait dans le texte
mais je sais que vous aimez beaucoup la
littérature qui c c'està-dire Céline
welbec vous l'avez dit récemment dans le
JDD vous déplorez justement une certaine
forme de littérature un peu
misérabiliste à la française où on
raconte sa vie donc comme vous l'avez
compris Matthieu ne parle pas du tout de
Macron mais comme par hasard ça me
rappelle vous savez il y a des années et
France s'en souvient la fameuse
couverture d'un livre sur giscar où on
le voyait déguiser en Louis XV France
oui on on démarre en 80 et on va jusqu'à
Macron euh je fait une classification
dont vous allez me dire si elle vous
correspond en fait donc nous avons
François mitteran Jacques Chirac Nicolas
Sarkozy François Holland Emmanuel Macron
ils sont C dans les livres précédents
vous aviez évidemment le général de
Gaulle georgees Pompidou et Giscard ce
que je perçois de ce que vous avez écrit
sur l'ensemble c'est que les trois
premiers avait à la fois une envie de
pouvoir évidente mais en même temps un
dessin politique réelle de Gaul sauveré
la France Pompidou la prospérité giscar
modernisé et à partir du moment où on
arrive à ceux que voici c'est-à-dire
cette dernière partie de la 5e
République c'est mitan Chirac Sarkozy
Hollande et Macron Macron estant un cas
un petit peu particulier au fond
j'essaie de c'est tellement dans ce que
vous racontez que j'essaie de donner une
vision générale au fond vous dites eux
ce sont des gens qui ont un peu oublié
le dessin voire même totalement oublié
le dessin et qui ont consacré leur vie
quitent à la perdre à la conquête du
pouvoir est-ce que vous faites cette
différence
ouais je je serais moins sévère en tout
cas sur certains je pense que en en gros
c'est vrai beaucoup sont dans uniquement
dans la conquête du pouvoir et après
comment le garder c'est clair et ce qui
explique voilà mais euh il y en a quand
même qui ont des dessins et puis le
dessin se perd avec le temps ce qui est
vrai c'est qu' à partir de
1981 pour des raisons évidentes qui sont
économiques le côté cont on a le
sentiment qu'il y a moins de contrôle si
vous voulez à partir de ce moment-là il
y a je dirais oui une sorte de peur qui
s'empare d'une de ces président de la
plupart de ces présidents même si c'est
pas vraiment assumé en tant que peur et
que au fond ils essayent de sauver les
mobles en tout cas pour certains d'entre
eux h je crois que c'est c'est c'est
c'est ce qui change à partir de là vous
décrivez un Chirac car le moment où il
accède pouvoir etvec qui Bab
malureux il est tétanisé pas tétanisé
triste malheureux c'est c'est c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui dès qu'il arrive
en 1995 à l'Élysée il est triste voilà
et puis il a été beaucoup trahi dans les
années qui précédent donc il n' plus
confiance
person voilà mais il y a un chapitre que
vous avez écrit qui est assez
passionnant qui s'appelle tout
simplement la plus grande trahison de la
5e République ouais bien sûr il faut
l'expliquer oui était bah un homme qui
l'avait fait qui était Édouard Baladur
qui avait été à partir de conversation a
Choné monorie vous avez oui alors c'est
un truc extraordinaire oui René monori
qui était Président du Sénat était
chargé par baladure de transmettre à
Méran le message que Chirac voulait
devenir quand même Premier ministre et
que parce que je pense que miteron
devait hésiter à mettre peut-être quand
même Chirac comme premier ministre après
la victoire écrasante de la droite vous
vous souvenez bien sûr en 1993
législative de 1993 la la gauche
n'existait plus c'était la le le Parti
socialiste de bergovois d'ailleurs
bergovois s'était suicidé sûrement en
parti aussi à cause de ça c'était une
défaite comme il restera dans les sur le
sur le cadavre de de bergovois qui a été
quand même assez populaire au moment il
éta au pouvoir vous expliquez que la
dette en France a explosé de plus de 13
% mais
RZ r alors donc donc donc euh euh il
voulait euh badure à tout prix être
nommé Premier ministre donc il fait dire
à miteran attention parce que si vous
pour vous amuser vous mettez vous
proposer Matignon à Chirac il risque
d'accepter et puis de vous embêter après
donc moi voilà je suis là et c'est le
message qui transmet et à partir de là
dès qu'il arrive à matigon Édouard
Baladur donc qui est comment dire moi
j'ai des souvenirs très précis de Chirac
qui vous appelle que je me souviens
quand j'étais au Figaro euh donc
j'étais directeur là et j'entendais
Chirac au téléphone qui me dit attention
j'ai donné un enfin éedouard vous a
envoyé un article ce serait très
intéressant enfin faudrait bien le
présenter c'est très important et cetera
il avait peur que le truc passe à la
série il était un peu la taché de presse
de baladure voyez ce que je veux dire
très engagé bon là il s'est fait trahir
dans les grandes largeur puisque tout de
suite le jour pratiquement où il arrive
à Matillon pas pratiquement le jour même
euh baladure organise comment dire sa sa
sa mise en scè pour l'Élysée puisqu'il
est tout de suite candidat et là si vous
voulez vous avez c'est fascinant
d'ailleurs de voir euh parce que c'est
devient très romanesque un homme abattu
blessé et qui même quand il a vaincu
baladure est triste parce que au fond
tout le monde l'a trahi et il n'a plus
confiance en personne je dirais même il
n'aime plus personne sauf Claude Chirac
et Jupé et Jean-Louis Debray je crois
que ça et peut-être tout bon j'en suis
même pas sûr enfin c'est très réduit son
petit cercle vous citez le général de
Gaul d'ailleurs à ce propos qui est cité
par Chirac dans la défaite de baladure
en disant au fond on peut pas gagner si
on ne si on ne participe pas à la
compétition si on fait pas la bagarre et
c'est évidemment ce que vous reprochez à
Bad ce qui est intéressant parce que
tout à l'heure j'aiévoqué votre vie mais
pas pour faire du bipol sordide c'est
parce que le nombre de cou non mais non
mais le nombre mais Mathie je sais pas
mais le nombre de coup deil quand vous
êtes patron du
nouvelops du Figaro ou du point que vous
recevez des hommes politiques c'est
extraordinaire je don deux exemples
engueades je vais donner deux exemples
puisque vous parlez de baladure baladure
n'arrête pas d'inviter à déjeuner Fran
dans les restaurants mou et cetera
d'ailleurs il a un petit bit baladure ce
qui prouve qu'il a quand même perdu une
certaine forme d'énergie et lui dit mais
alors enfin quand est-ce que vous allez
prendre officiellement parti pour moi
pour la campagne et vous évidemment vous
ricanez et vous ne faites rien j'ai une
dernière question avant qu'on ait une
conversation commune sur la situation
actuelle parce que effectivement il faut
aboutir à à la situation actuelle si je
vous dis mitéran Chirac Sarkozi à qui
vous consacrez je trouve pas beaucoup de
pages François Hollande ou Emmanuel
Macron quel est celui qui a fait le plus
de bien ou le moins de mal oh c'est très
compliqué comm attendez attende par mais
ne tournez
pas habitez MARSEILLE montez dans la
barque qui R moi attendez je suis très
honnête j'ai repris d'ailleurs beaucoup
de notes c'est tout ce que je raconte et
pratiquement j'avais c'est entre
guillemets cciisation oui puis j'avais
surtout je tenais mon journal à l'époque
pendant au moins 15 ans donc oui mais je
réponds c'est il y a toujours du pour et
du contre c'est-à-dire non mais attendez
il faut être honnête j'essaie d'être
honnête moi je suis un journaliste
honnête je suis pas un journaliste
militant chez mitan il y avait très bon
côté je suis désolé il y avait sur le
plan économique c'est un désastre total
mais ça cétait fait bourrer le crâne ou
le mou par Fabius bergovois Thal et
compagnie on va faire des dépenses
samptuaires et ça va faire déécoller
l'économie non non mais enfin il y avait
toutes ces bêtises enfin voilà il faut
dépenser il faut voilà ça va relancer
l'économie on a vu un désastre
absolu il y avait beaucoup de profondeur
non je répète que chacun a des défauts
et desal alors pourquoi vous avez
marginalisé un peu Nicolas Sarkozi à qui
vous consacrez pas énormément de pages
non je
qu le bon père gber non non mais je
consacre autant de page je crois à à à
François Hollande c'est un moment
important
mais Nicolas Sarkozy avec lequel j'ai eu
des relations épouvantables j'essaie
d'être honnête et l'honnêteté m'oblige à
dire qu'il a essayé de faire des choses
et qu'on peut pas dire que le bilan est
nul je veux dire son bilan en 5 ans est
certainement plus important que sera
celui de Macron en 10 ans donc euh il il
a fait des choses donc euh euh quand je
peux pas dire celui-là c'est bien
celui-ci c'est pas bien c'est pas c'est
pas digne je trouve que on peut pas nous
journalistes travailler comme ça si je
je raconte chacun avec ses problèmes che
par exemple regardez Shira qui dormait
tout le temps dormait c'est vrai que la
phrase de de sarkoosi contre lui ce
qu'il appelle le roi fait néant il y
avait quelque chose comme ça et puis en
même temps brusquement il se réveillait
et il disait des choses choses fortes il
les faisait même la loi sur le voil la
laïité enfin voilà il il y a des choses
fortes c'est dire c'est quelqu'un qui se
réveillait il y avait donc vous voyez
ils ont il y avait de la puissance chez
lui donc vous voyez donc vous pouvez pas
comment dire pour arriver à être
président de la République
excusez-moi enfin on sait ce que c'est
cette course avec tout tous les
c'est quand même il faut quand même un
minimum de talent c'estd on peut pas à
la poubelle tous ces gens comme ça c'est
pas possible arrive à la conversation ça
c'est du populisme du dégagisme je ne
suis pas làdedans ce n'est je vous ai
posé une question après moi je fais un
bilan cruel c'est vrai je souvent très
cruel j'ai parfois un peu h ce que de ce
que j'ai écrit mais c'était c'était ce
que j'ai noté souvent à l'époque vous
voyez ce que je veux dire le bilan en
fond pour qu'on arrive à la conversation
commune le bilan que fait France pour
simplifier mais est assez juste c'est
une gigantesque erreur économique depuis
80 jusqu'à maintenant voilà et tout le
monde a continué en partie lié à
justement la crainte du peuple français
après des réformes l'argent magique
allez c'est pas grave on va on va faire
des CHCs
etés mtenant je voudrais qu'on réintègre
notre camarade Mathieu qui est quand
même venu pas très loin de chez vous
d'ex Provence pour nous voir avec le roi
etu parce que l'une des caractéristiques
de Macron contrairement aux autres c'est
que dès 2017 on le revoit maintenant et
c'est aussi un peu la la thèse que vous
défendez au fond les partis il st
contrefous il s'est fait élire contre
les partis contre le Parti socialiste
contre le LR le fait de nommer Gabriel
ATA et de reprendre Madame Dati c'est
aussi une manière encore une fois de
leur faire un bras d'honneur François
berou avec le Modem ils sont absolument
foudrage et ça c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas et je parle en présence de
France qui nétait pas totalement le
raisonnement des prédécesseurs qui
justement noyotait les partis créait les
partis euh chouchouit les partis euh
répartissaient les ministres en fonction
des territoires et CETA et là c'est
quelque chose qui a absolument changé et
c'est vraiment le cœur de votre romance
c'està qu'au fond les partis pour
Macron voulant devenir le roi ça n'a
aucune importance Mathieu c'est vrai
après il y a un peu ça je trouve chez
Nicolas Sarkozi au début dans son son
gouvernement d'aller prendre des
ministres un peu de T voilà mais j'ai
l'impression a voilà qu'il a que
Emmanuel Macron a poussé ça un peu à
l'excès euh après les parties
effectivement est-ce que est-ce que
c'est un moment de l'histoire où ces
partis doivent disparaître
et je sais pas je sais pas si encore les
les la jeunesse aujourd'hui a envie de
s'investir dans des partis politiques si
vous voulez est-ce que c'est pas quelque
chose qui est passé de mode où on a
effectivement des gens qui sont
influenceurs youtubeurs et cetera qui
ont finalement plus de de gens qui les
écoutent peut-être que de que de de
chefs de parti politique ouis c'est
comme les fidèles à la messe quoi c'est
comme les fidèles à la messe il y a
moins de monde voilà donc je je
peut-être que qu'Emmanuel Macron
effectivement a senti ça et s'est dit en
fait les partis c'est terminé c'est un
c'est un vieux truc il faut passer à
autre chose peut-être que ce n'est qu'un
moment et qu'en fait les partis vont se
reformer euh j'ai l'impression qu'on a
quand même le le rassemblement national
qui pour le coup est dans un parti qui
se construit et qui prend de la place
donc qui va forcément obliger à mon avis
les autres à se reconstruire h donc je
sais pas on verra aux européennes je
pense que ça va donner vous avez un joli
regard qui cherche justement dans les
lumières de bonheur des livres la
réponse à cette question qui est une
question que se pose beaucoup de gens de
ce point de vue-l France avec
l'expérience du journaliste et aussi du
romancier comme Mathieu est-ce qu'on est
dans une phase de destruction terrible
et en même temps dans une phase de
rajeunissement c'est un peu le thème
Barbé là àal et les autres vont
disparaître ou est-ce que tout ça est
une illusion totale bah je c je crois
beaucoup moi la théorie ancienne vous
savez l'éternel retour il y a quelque
chose qui nous permet de comprendre
l'économie euh c'est
un économiste russe qui a inventé ça
s'appelle les cycles de conratief et je
crois qu'il y a des cycles de conratief
aussi concernant les partis politiques
c'est-à-dire que j'ai quand même un
certain nombre d'h d'heur de vol hein ça
fait plus d'un demisècle que je traîne
mes guêes dans le journalisme et
j'entends dire assez régulièrement c'est
fini les partis ou alors on va
réinventer la politique ce que faisait
giscar ce que fait aujourd'hui Macron
c'est-à-dire autour d'un bloc central et
puis au bout d'un certain temps les
choses se réorganisent un peu comme
auparavant donc effectivement les partis
vont très mal je pense qu' un moment
donné ça va revenir et notre ami Falcon
dit quelque chose de très juste c'est
que dans la mesure où le parti le grand
parti aujourd'hui attrape tout qui est
le rassemblement national se renforce à
peu près tous les jours dans dans dans
les sondages euh il y a forcément en
face des partis qui vont s'organiser
mais c'est la loi de la vie donc il y a
des hauts il y a des bas enfin on c'est
tout ça mais si je si je vous pose cette
question à tous les deux c'est parce que
il y a des moments où il faut parler de
la France il faut sortir de France aussi
on se rend compte que l'Allemagne par
exemple et vous en parlez d'ailleurs qui
a pendant longtemps été le Phénix de la
réussite économique connait les
résultats épouvantables et vous France
qui avez été correspondant aux
États-Unis pendant des années parce que
vous avez fait ça au aussi on vient
d'avoir le résultat de l'owa concernant
la primaire des républicains c'est vous
avez un Trump qui poursuivit par la
justice et par la presse à longueur de
journée et qui vient de l'emporter avec
pratiquement 50 % des des voix largement
de dans ses concurrents donc on a quand
même l'impression oui mais ça
excusez-moi c'est une victoire qui a été
fabriquée parce que je l'ai écrit à
l'époque toutes ces actions justice
contre Trump à à plus d'un an de de
l'élection présidentielle des actions
qui auraient pu être faites il depuis
longtemps vous parlez du gouvernement
des juges non mais ça c'est quelque
chose qui devait faire monter Trump on
peut soupçonner d'ailleurs Joe Biden qui
est un grand président par ailleurs
d'avoir pensé que Trump était son
meilleur d'ailleurs rival et d'ailleurs
il a tout de suite dit voilà c'est la
grande victoire de Trump ça l'arrange je
pense que avec qui allit ou Rand De
Santis qui sont les deux rivaux de Trump
je pense que ce serait plus compliqué
Ave Biden qui est quand même dans une
position compliquée même si son bilan
est loin d'être mauvais et il est dans
une position très compliquée simplement
à cause de l'âge je pense qu'il préfère
avoir Trump donc si vous voulez faut
faut aussi relativiser la victoire de
Trump je pense que les médias par leurs
attaques la justice ont beaucoup pidé
Trump je dois dire que le livre de
France justement ce se termine en partie
euh par un chapitre sur la justice en
France et vous n'épargnez pas les juges
notamment évidemment depuis la lu juge
partisan parce qu' grand juge hein quand
même d'accord notamment euh depuis
l'affaire du mur des cons et des
attaques contre Nicolas Sarkozi via le
le PNF et vous allez lire tout ça est-ce
que vous avez l'impression Mathieu euh
merci d'être venu on était ravi oui mais
grand livre grand livre parce que c'est
vous avez bien fait de l'invité euh ça
m'a amusé quand il a parit de Maurice
dantc qui a fait des très bons
livresaby qui nous a quitté il y a la
sirène rouge mais euh j'ai pensé aussi à
Tom Wolf ça parce qu' il y a dedans une
espèce d'humour sur notre époque et je
trouve qu'il parle merveilleusement bien
de notre époque est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que quelque chose Mathieu
justement dans cette espèce de délire
que vous avez inventé d'un pouvoir
puissant au fond la monarchie ça fait
partie de de ce contexte qu'on évoquéit
avec France qui est un contexte
international avec Poutine qui veut
écraser l'Europe Erdogan qui entre
guillemets même si les élections se
contrefout de la démocratie et et et et
évidemment ce qu'on
connaî dans le monde actuel avec les
Chinois enfin de plus en plus de pays
qui tournent le dos à ce que nous avons
vénéré à savoir le fait d'aller élire un
président un beau matin d'une manièreou
on est dans une une comment dire une
situation où il y a de plus en plus de
crise on l'a vu avec le covid avec ce
genre de de choses de plus en plus
mondialisé donc forcément les pouvoirs
se renforcent et est-ce qu'on aurait
imaginé qu'on serait qu'on accepterait
d'être confiné chez nous de montrer un
passe pour sortir d'avoir des couvre-feu
finalement c'est passé à peu près comme
une lettre à la poste donc même en
France en Europe on arrive à d'ù d'où
d'où les populistes en France d'où
l'extrême droite en Allemagne
extrêmement haut d'où les populistes en
France et des gens effectivement des
mouvements qui ont envie de de renverser
ça pour peut-êtreagner une liberté
illusoire je sais pas mais en tout cas
pour changer et faire autre chose oui
nous n'allons pas nous jouer totalement
le jeu des pronostics mais c'est vrai
que le rassemblement nationale donc à la
dans la perspective des européennes et
euh pour l'instant extrêmement bien
placé je voudrais vous rappeler ces
livres celui de jisber c'est le 3è tome
donc il il faut lire les deux premiers
le premier c'est le sursaut c'est ça
France sursut général de Gaulle la Belle
Époque ensuite tome 2 voilà avec gcidou
et giscar voilà et l'histoire intime de
la 5e République c'est bourré
d'anecdotes de conversations de déjeuner
j'en ai évoqué quelquesuns mais nous ne
pouvons pas les évoquer tous et
évidemment ça concerne tous les
présidents que vous connaissez et puis
donc euh la version romanesque bien que
Fran soit par définition romanesque il a
écrit très bon roman de Matthieu Falcon
le roi est nu donc l'idée un peu farfelu
qu'un personnage qui n'est pas Emmanuel
Macron mais qui lui ressemble fortement
je remets la petite photo inventée par
l'éditeur pourrait tout d'un coup se se
décider à faire non pas un deuxème
mandat mais un référendum qui gagne
d'ailleurs à 51 % vous donnez carrément
le chiffre 51,2 % qui gagne pour
installer une sorte de monarchie leur
constitutionnel ou pas on ne le sait pas
mais en tout cas Mathieu peut vous faire
d'une certaine manière rêver merci à
tous les deux d'être venusci beaucoup
c'était au bonheur des livres c'est un
vrai bonheur de lire ces deux
[Musique]
livres